-Performing
"Dancing Away in Tears" from her
Grammy-nominated album
"Stand for Myself," here's Yola.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ We're dancing away ♪
♪ In tears ♪
♪ The music we make ♪
♪ Disappears ♪
♪ Breaking up
is always hard to do ♪
♪ One last dance
is all I want with you ♪
♪ I can't go
and do it all again ♪
♪ And pretend
that I ever wanted to ♪
♪ We're dancing away ♪
♪ In tears ♪
♪ The music we make ♪
♪ Disappears ♪
♪ The party is over,
now we're on the floor ♪
♪ You're not mine,
and, baby, I'm not yours ♪
♪ I can't go
and do it all again ♪
♪ And pretend that
we were never something more ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Goodbye, baby ♪
♪ Goodbye, love ♪
♪ I wish you well ♪
♪ Well enough ♪
♪ Oh, goodbye baby ♪
♪ Goodbye, love ♪
♪ It was good ♪
♪ Now it's gone ♪
♪ Oh, breaking up
is always hard to do ♪
♪ One last dance
is all I want with you ♪
♪ I can't go
and do it all again ♪
♪ And pretend
that I ever wanted to ♪
♪ Breaking up
is always hard to do ♪
♪ One last dance
is all I want with you ♪
♪ I can't go
and do it all again ♪
♪ And pretend
that I ever wanted to ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Ah, ah ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, ohhhhh ♪
♪ Goodbye, baby ♪
♪ Goodbye, love ♪
♪ I wish you well ♪
♪ Well enough ♪
♪ Oh, goodbye, baby ♪
♪ Goodbye, love ♪
♪ I wish you well ♪
♪ Well ♪
-♪ Goodbye, baby ♪
-♪ Oh, oh ♪
-♪ Goodbye, love ♪
♪ I wish you well ♪
-♪ Oh, whoa ♪
-♪ Well enough ♪
-♪ Oh, oh ♪
-♪ Goodbye, baby ♪
-♪ Goodbye ♪
♪ Oh, ooh ♪
♪ Oh, hey ♪
♪ Well enough ♪